venom has finally started its theatrical
run and like most comic book movies of
the modern era it contains several
post-credit scenes thirty sequels and
what is to come throughout this video
I'll be discussing both credit scenes
for the film so there will be heavy
spoilers with that out the way and
definition and I ruin the movie so you
don't have to the first post-credit
scene of venom sees Eddie Brock played
by Tom Hardy and during a present to
interview Cletus Kasady played by Woody
Harrelson fans of the spider-man comics
will instantly recognize the name as the
alter ego of Venom's nemesis carnage
Cassidy speaks to Brock and says do you
want to know what me being a serial
killer is like do you want to know the
carnage that's the end of the first
post-credit scene yeah yeah the writing
is bad it's bad still though I'm quite
excited to see where they go with a
character in future and Harrelson
definitely has the acting chops to pull
off the role
but those unaware carnage is a symbiote
similar to venom but with more rage and
a desire to kill driven by Cassidy's
insane personality the other post
credits scene starts up once all titles
have rolled and we see in another spider
burrs appear on the screen the trailer
for spider-man into the spider verse
then plays and teases what is next to
come from Sony Studios so what do you
think of the post-credits scene for
venom you feel a bit let down by one of
them just being a trailer that we've
already seen all are you excited for
what's to come
and what would you like to see in future
sequels comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and subscribe to my
channel I create content like this
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on here that you love if
you're a fan of film recently I covered
the ending of the new Netflix film hold
the dark so make sure you check that our
next linked at the end of this one
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]